en pleno centro de budapest en esta
conocida librería este libro ocupa el
sexto lugar entre los más vendidos se
titula el país de las maravillas le
pertenece a todo el mundo una antología
de cuentos que incluye a las minorías
los citantes las personas que viven en
la pared las personas el eje de tq pero
es ese último grupo el que más ha
llamado la atención últimamente el
primer ministro calificó el libro de
propaganda homosexual y el gobierno
pidió que fuera vendido con una
calcomanía de advertencia a partir de
septiembre una nueva ley restringir a la
venta de todo el libro que contenga
contenido el ejemplar sólo podremos
venderlo si está empacado y separado de
los demás productos cómo se hace eso
además la librería no debe estar ubicada
a menos de 200 metros de una iglesia o
de un establecimiento escolar para este
editor es imposible seguir trabajando en
hungría decidió irse del país incluso
aunque admita que los húngaros no son
tan fóbicos como su gobierno parece
pensar hay estudios y encuestas que
muestran que la población húngara no es
tan intolerante frente a las personas
pero la campaña del gobierno conlleva
una radicalización de ambos lados
ya era mismo fóbicos o transfóbicos se
sienten alentados este ticket afuera de
la librería esta pareja de
universitarios o no duda en expresar
abiertamente su punto de vista y dijo
que he escuchado hablar sobre este libro
de cuentos
creo que no está bien
pensamos que no está bien exponer a los
niños a ese tipo de cosas
estas restricciones sobre los libros se
hacen en el marco de otra ley
introducida en julio que prohíbe el
contenido el gp en la educación sexual y
en los programas para niños ante las
medidas legales establecidas por la
unión europea hungría anunció la
realización de un referéndum sobre lo
que el gobierno llamó la protección
infantil
pienso que la razón de ser de esta ley
es saber si ese fin doble
desde un punto de vista moral o ético o
de
la teoría del género y
ringo propaganda aquí se habla de teoría
y de propaganda pero la reciente
política del gobierno tuvo un impacto
concreto sobre las vidas de las parejas
del mismo sexo que querían ser padres
márton y su esposo adoptaron un niño
hace cuatro años pero hoy en día no
pueden darle a su hijo un hermano o una
hermana desde el año pasado todas las
adopciones deben pasar directamente por
el ministerio de asuntos familiares
[Música]
la litera realmente no está a favor de
la familia celeste ni de la
homoparentalidad
entonces creo que nuestras posibilidades
son todavía menores que a la cuenta de
instagram de márton y adam tiene 53 mil
seguidores la pareja trata de mostrar
cómo es la vida normal de una familia el
gmt aquí está estábamos celebrando el
día de su adopción como es posible
llamar a esto una ideología aquí se
habla de emociones del corazón de amor
a las personas que aman por supuesto
queremos lo mejor para nuestros niños a
principios de agosto durante un festival
estudiantil la portavoz del gobierno
sugirió que le gustaría ver disminuir la
influencia de las cuentas de instagram a
como la de márton y adam es necesario en
este momento se habla mucho sobre eso
pero todavía no se ha podido hacer
circular las redes sociales de manera
apropiada
el organizador del festival un instituto
conservador que acaba de recibir 15 mil
millones de euros en efectivo y en
activos de parte del gobierno y como
participante estrella el polemista
estadounidense de derecha toca el calcio
a quien había preparado una dura
acusación contra la hungría de viktor
orbán más del 90 por ciento de los
medios están controlados por el partido
en el poder
las elecciones están manipuladas sin
embargo este discurso era evidentemente
irónico y constituía una burla a las
críticas contra víctor ahora leo todas
esas cosas le parecen hilarantes una
intervención apreciada por esta
profesora
estamos viviendo una especie de
sobresalto no es un sobresalto liberal
sino un sobresalto conservador
aquí la mayoría de los jóvenes aprueban
las restricciones de acceso para los
niños ante el contenido
y votarán a favor en el referéndum
cualquier persona cuerda sabrá
inmediatamente cómo votar basta con leer
las preguntas y la respuesta resulta
evidente
pero incluso entre esta muchedumbre de
conservadores se oyen algunas voces
disidentes
antes de cada elección designan una
comunidad contra la cual las personas
podrán dirigir su odio
así fue con la crisis migratoria y ahora
el gobierno escogió la comunidad lgtb
como objetivo con la esperanza de
seducir a los electores y ganar votos
pero los viernes en la noche en budapest
park pueden generar dudas sobre la
eficacia de la estrategia gubernamental
todas las semanas estas veladas atraen
personas de todas las edades y de todas
las orientaciones sexuales lo que
hicimos organizado una fiesta adultos de
la noche sino una serie de eventos
alrededor de la temática de gerente para
que todo el mundo se sintiera cómodo y
bienvenido para quiroga y phoenix el
apoyo a los derechos cl gmt q se acentuó
desde la introducción de estas leyes
homofóbicas la mayoría de personas
estaban tranquilas con la situación tal
como estaba pero el gobierno está
cruzando una línea roja está forzando a
las personas a tomar partido y escoger
un banco pero los militantes llaman al
boicot del referéndum cuyas preguntas
son según ellos tendenciosas